a party goods company is making novelty
crowns out of paper they start with a
rectangular piece of paper and then cut
three semi-circles each with a six inch
diameter out of the top to create a
crown so they start with a rectangle and
then they cut these semi-circles out of
the top of that rectangle find the area
and perimeter of the crown below so
let's just start with the perimeter of
it so we have to find the lengths of
each of these semicircle arcs right over
here and then add those and then add
them to these lengths over here which is
with that latter part is pretty
straightforward but let's just think
about how long
how long this is right over here that
i'm highlighting in blue and we know
that this is a semicircle it is half of
a full circle that has diameter six and
if we wanted to know the circumference
of the entire circle the encircumference
of this entire circle is given by and
this really comes straight out of the
definition of pi it's pi times the
diameter or another way to think about
the diameter's two radiuses so it's two
pi times the radius but they give us the
diameter right over here the diameter is
six inches the diameter is six inches so
the circumference this entire
circumference right over here is going
to be equal to the circumference is
equal to 6 pi that's the circumference
of the entire circle if we think about
there's the circumference of one of the
semicircles so circumference of or maybe
i should say the length of a semicircle
is going to be half of this it's half
the circle so this length right over
here is going to be 3 pi
and then this one is the exact same
length is going to be 3 pi again
half of the circumference of the entire
circle and then this over here is going
to be 3 pi again and now we're ready to
figure out the perimeter
you have 3
3 3 pi's so it's going to be 3 times 3
pi
plus
6 inches
plus 6
plus 18
plus 6 again
plus 6 again so this is 9 pi that's this
part right over there 9 pi plus so this
is going to be 12 plus 18 plus 30.
that's the perimeter and if we wanted to
if we wanted to let me write this down
this is equal to the perimeter and if we
wanted to get the exact number you could
substitute 3.14 for a rough
approximation of pi or we could get our
calculator out and get the exact or
pretty close to the exact number
even the calculator doesn't have an
infinite precision for pi but let's
let's get the calculator out and if we
want to get
9
pi 9 times pi
plus 30
that gets us 56 58 point and i'll just
round to the hundreds 58.27
inches
58.27 inches so it's equal to
58.27 and it's inches because all of
these units were in inches
52.58.27 inches that's our perimeter now
let's think about the area to figure out
the area what we can do is we can figure
out the area of the rectangle before
they cut out these circles so the area
of the entire rectangle and then we can
subtract from that the area of these
semicircles so the area of the rectangle
the area of the rectangle is just the
base times the height it's equal to 18
times 6 inches let me write the units
down
18 inches
times 6
inches and this is equal to
10 times 6 is 60 8 times 6 is 48 so it
becomes 108
inches squared
inches
inches squared 108 square inches that's
the area of the entire rectangle we're
not done yet because we haven't cut out
the semicircles the area
if these were complete circles if you
think about them as complete circles the
area of a complete circle is pi r
squared so area of a circle is going to
be pi times the radius squared the
diameter here is six the radius here is
going to be three so the radius is going
to be three inches so it's pi times
three inches squared which is equal to
9 pi
square inches that's for each of these
complete circles so it's 9 pi for each
of the complete ones if you take half of
them
i'll write it over here
area of the semi-circle
is going to be
nine pi
over two
inches or squared inches and we have
three of them we have three of these of
these semi-circles so the area of this
crown i'll do it this in pink the area
of the crown is going to be equal to the
area of the rectangle which is 108
square inches
minus 3 times the area of the
semicircles minus this minus this minus
this minus 3 of the semicircles minus 3
times
9 pi
over 2
inches
squared and this is equal to 108 minus
what is this minus 27
over 2
pi
inches squared and you could leave it
that way if you just wanted to leave it
in terms of pi
but as we know pi is a number and we can
use our calculator to evaluate it
we get
the calculator out we have
108
minus
27 i'll just write as 27 pi over 2
27 pi
divided by 2
right 108 minus 27 pi divided by 2
will give us
it will give us 65 and if i round to
165.5
inches
square inches to be exact or to be get
the right units
65.65.59 square inches so this is equal
to
65.5
inches squared and we are done